so as you might know Donald Trump likes
to portray himself as sort of the alpha
male and that's the way a lot of his
supporters like to portray him also he
says what's on his mind he's in charge
in the room he does the masculine you
know handshake games with whoever he
meets everybody else is a beta cuck
compared to the alpha male of the pack
Donald Trump well turns out that Turkish
president air Dewan was interviewed by
PBS newshour and he said to Judy
Woodruff that Donald Trump apologised to
him about the incident where air diwan's
own bodyguards came to the United States
and beat up protesters out on the
streets is there anything more bata than
apologizing to a foreign leaders but to
a foreign leader that his bodyguards had
to beat people up when he visited your
country I have the clip but I'll remind
you about the story first back in May
Turkish president air Diwan came to the
United States and outside the Turkish
embassy there were protesters they were
protesting air Dewan for his absolutely
brutal repression in Turkey which I've
been covering for a long time and air
diwan's bodyguards got into this big
brawl with the protesters they kicked a
woman in the face if I remember
correctly left a ton of people bloodied
and injured absolutely insane attacks so
there are people wondering well when is
Trump going to hold air dhawan and his
bodyguards accountable for their
behavior when they were guests in the
United States but according to president
air Diwan it was Trump who apologized to
him take a look at this clip you get
along with President Trump how can you
do business with President Trump when
when there is this fundamental
disagreement over what happened that day
I'm very sorry about that actually
President Trump called me about a week
ago about this issue he said that he was
sorry that he told me that he was going
to follow up on this issue when we come
to the United States within the
framework of an official visit now the
White House is disputing this of course
White House spokesman the White House
spokes responded and they said no they
talked about a lot of things but Donald
Trump did not apologize
say sorry for what happened there the
only thing that makes me doubt whether
like the Trump's spokespeople lie all
the time okay so the fact that the Trump
White House is denying that Trump did
this carries no weight for me the thing
that's making me question whether Trump
apologized is I'm not aware of Trump
ever apologizing for anything and that
makes me doubt whether he might have
actually apologized here well neither
one of the parties here have any
credibility but you know if rwan is
telling the truth here I mean can't we
point to Republicans criticizing Barack
Obama for going on this apology tour
where he apologized for maybe like the
war in Iraq or he'd go to Hiroshima and
apologize for the the nuclear bombings
there or at least take some
responsibility and right-wingers would
bash him say he was going on an apology
tour whereas Donald Trump is willing to
say is sorry to the president of Turkey
oh so he should be applauded for this
actually if the guy can take
responsibility that's an interesting
point of view I don't know how anyone
can defend what actually took place
right I mean how can Republicans defend
the beating up of protesters by foreign
visitors was it they were liberal
troublemakers and they deserved it and
if it's true that Donald Trump
apologized to President arrow on for
this consider the list of people that
Donald Trump seems to defer to to some
way in some way look up to or to use
their term I don't use this term to be
cocked by it's Vladimir Putin it's
president air Dewan it's Filipino leader
Rodrigo Duterte who Trump said is doing
an unbelievable job in fighting the drug
war when what the guy is doing is
basically sanctioning and promoting
unlawful or extrajudicial vigilantism in
the streets maybe Trump should be
apologizing to erawan for not knowing
how to pronounce his name
yeah well guys Aragon that would be a
good start I would like to see that
apology I don't expect to see that one
anytime soon